[Musique]
quel silence mirabel et p'tit louis ont
l'air très sage ce soir où ils dorment
déjà
ou alors ils sont vraiment très absorbé
par un travail où ils me prépare une
nouvelle blague mais gros ours ils
adorent ça vaut pas toujours patron pas
toujours europe et courage nounours mon
petit doigt me dit que ce soir ils vont
être très gentil que votre peau propos
pour pop en propre apport aussi lâché
cloud s'échappe au tu crois moi je
trouve un peu lourd à toulouse ne bouge
pas le bouchon tout bas
[Musique]
et à demain
je crois qu'il vaut mieux que je
revienne demain non je crois qu'il est
très tard il vaut mieux que je m'en
aille
tu vois rose youth tu fais un très bon
chapeau pour maman pour lui offrir
dimanche où ça fait mal là beaucoup de
sites ne pense pas qu'ils lui l'accord m
et celle ci au bas du dos alors ben non
ça suffit comme j'ai fait au japon tout
seul voyons les enfants royaux de tous
est réservé aux pas au roi lion
oui aux no
par pitié
audio bose ou non le mieux
non non je crois qu'il est très bien
comme ça chapeau c'est vrai mais oui il
est très réussie ce soit pour elle va
être très content de votre bambin
oui on sait les ravages qui lui donne
ses jeunes pour moi je donne autre chose
inouïe il venait acheter un cadeau à way
avec les soupes matière les chevaliers
acheter quelque chose de très bons c'est
très gentil ça mais quoi peut-être un
collier avec un diamant
oui ou alors quelque chose dont elle a
besoin dans la maison et qui lui manque
après si quand c'est pas beau mais mieux
acheter des pantoufles c'est une
excellente idée
[Musique]
toi toi nous nous ce qu'est ce que tu
lâches et à ta maman
moi je vais lui acheter un joli carnet
pourquoi faire un joli carnet de bridge
oui elle joue au bridge avec ses amis
c'est une championne
[Musique]
voilà patron j'arrive à l'on dormait
vite les enfants
la nuit porte conseil
là j'éteins la lumière higuero belle
elle est marrante la maman de gros offre
enfin oui elle joue briques venait-il
bihorel
vous aussi les petits enfants allez vite
vous coucher embrassez vos parents et
surtout n'oubliez pas dimanche de
souhaiter bonne fête à votre maman
car dimanche ce sera la fête de toutes
les mamans du monde couple oui mais moi
je vais vite lui acheter mon cadeau et
écrire à ma maman c'est très bien ça ne
nous fait un bon fils au revoir les
enfants
bonne nuit bonne nuit
oh
[Musique]